buckle up tonight big breaking news
multiple fronts including more
embarrassing gaffes I mean really bad
ones
it seems sleepy creepy crazy Uncle Joe
didn't even know what state he was in
and it gets worse
and as feckless 2020 campaign is hanging
in the balance he is now in third place
in a major poll also a major update from
the president's ongoing trade
negotiations with China the president's
winning that's the start we'll tell you
more about that but we began a shocking
new development out of the deep state
we can confirm tonight the DOJ inspector
general's investigation into FISA abuse
that's the Michael Horowitz report has
now been completed and according to the
hills John Solomon the IG s findings
could be released as early as the next
couple of weeks it's now being processed
for potential redactions Lindsey Graham
says he expects the findings to be quote
damning and ugly and he will want all of
it released and he will give the
Inspector General as much time as he
needs to tell the entire story of this
abuse of power and corruption now of
course one of the key targets of the
investigation is likely mr. super super
Patriot himself Jim Comey as we all know
by now was Comey who signed off on the
very first FISA application against
Donald Trump and his campaign associate
Carter page we also now know he signed
to other FISA applications all based the
bulk of information the Borton bought
and paid for phony Russian dossier
bought and paid for by Hillary Clinton
he swore three times that the evidence
in those applications were true accurate
and verified in reality in truth none of
it was any of the above none of it was
true none of it was verified and Comey
was lying now his first FISA requests
relied on Hillary's bought and paid for
dirty dossier Russian dossier that
wasn't true
neither was the second a third warrant I
was all based on the phony dossier
none of it accurate none of it
verifiable it was all unverifiable
garbage Comey knew the Intel was BS he
was warned specifically on multiple
occasions by multiple people and
multiple sources no serious attempt was
ever made
to verify the dossiers claims that he
signed off on three times Comey used it
in a way in order to secure a backdoor
into all things Trump campaign then
transition and then the trump presidency
so it's clear Jim Comey committed
premeditated fraud and a FISA Court in
order to spy on a presidential campaign
transition and presidency now meanwhile
commis right-hand man former deputy
director Andrew McCabe he was fired from
the FBI last year for lying and leaking
but guess what McCabe he'll fit right in
he was just hired by fake new CNN they
claimed to be the facts first Network
they can't break a million viewers in a
single hour that is a disaster for any
network and breaking tonight as we speak
as we speak federal prosecutors are
reportedly nearing a final decision on
whether or not the former deputy FBI
director McCabe will in fact be indicted
over his egregious lying wait a minute
they went after manna for for lying and
Papadopoulos for lying and Cohen for
lying and general Flynn for lying do we
have equal justice under the law and get
this his former colleague fellow Trump
hater Lisa Paige well she may be the
deciding factor here now to explain all
of this breaking news is a very own
catherine herridge in washington tonight
catherine big breaking story especially
good evening a source close to the
matter tells Fox News that federal
prosecutors appear close to a decision
over whether to charge former FBI deputy
and Acting Director Andrew McCabe for
lying to investigators New York Times
first reported that McCabe's legal team
met last week with the Deputy Attorney
General and US attorney for DC the
Justice Department declined to comment
but these meetings are often used by the
defense as they're lost shop to argue
against their clients indictment McCabe
a frequent target of the president was
fired last year after the Justice
Department's inspector general Michael
Horowitz found he lacked candor under
oath over his role in a media leak about
the FBI's Clinton Foundation
investigation
three weeks ago mckay filed this 48-page
lawsuit against the FBI in justice
department for wrongful termination and
recently McCabe joined as you mentioned
CNN as a contributor earlier this year
he told the network the allegations are
false and he
the white house I think the president
had an indelible impact on the IGS
process I know that the process that I
went through was one that was unfair was
one that left out multiple pieces of
relevant information the testimony of
witnesses who were never even referenced
in the report tonight McCabe's legal
team did not respond to Fox's request
for comment when it comes to lying or
lack of candor under oath what matters
here according to former FBI agents is
that the bureau is held to a higher
standard because they are the one Shawn
that enforced the law well Katherine
I'll tell you one thing that I think is
unfair didn't McCabe tell Lieutenant
General Flynn a 33-year veteran that he
didn't need a lawyer
just prior to Comey bragging about
sending people in that he would never do
that in the bush or the Obama
administration's to take advantage of
the chaos knowing it was an
interrogation wouldn't that be to me
that sounds like Miranda right
violations that seems unfair they knew
was investigation but I don't want to
drag you into the narrative but that
won't happen right it's hopefully gonna
come up in the next few weeks well they
did brag about it they did say the
general Flynn you don't need a lawyer
and Comey did brag that he took
advantage of the chaos which he wouldn't
do in the Obama or Bush administration's
great reporting as always in Washington
tonight after inherit now without a
doubt it was a big weekend for fake news
CNN on top of the hiring of the former
FBI FBI director who was fired for lying
and leaking well we have Jeff suckers
stenographer professional Fox News hater
brian Stelter humpty dumpty giving a
platform to some pretty shocking
accusations letting it go unchallenged
of course it's all happening on a
sparsely watch low rated weekend show
humpty dumpty featuring a deranged
armchair psychologist supposedly from
Duke claiming Trump may be responsible
for more deaths get this then Hitler
Stalin and Mao have a lot more special
monologue for Humpty later in the
program but naturally Humpty Dumpty and
fake news CNN also dutifully defended
their big new hire you know the guy
fired for lying and leaking Andrew
McCabe and by the way McCabe was fired
from that job as we said under
super Patriot Jim Comey now McCabe might
face criminal charges as we're reporting
tonight but on humpty-dumpty show McCabe
was held for his quote serious expertise
watch now CNN hired Andrew McCabe
formerly the FBI was fired from the FBI
he was accused of lying in a leak
investigation and people on the right
said well you're hiring McCabe well why
can't fox hire Spicer is there a
difference as fire why can't fox hire
sanders is there a difference do you see
if there's a difference Andrew McCabe is
gonna bring serious expertise with
respect to the FBI and investigations
and he in no way was accused of standing
in front of the American people and
lying to them he was accused of lack of
candor and talking about talking to the
press that the proportion the scale and
the substance are utterly not comparable
same fake news network that has been
peddling lies conspiracy theories and
the biggest hoax in American history
every single minute second hour of every
24 hour day week month and year just a
prime example of why Stelter and his
employer by the way the president is
forever rightly branded them fake News
CNN lacks any credibility they pretend
to be arbiters of truth and facts but in
reality they're nothing more than
propaganda arm of the Democratic Party